how about now hey there it is
sorry
[Music]
sorry about that here we go here we go
can we hear now i know the chat's a
little bit delayed so
what about now
everybody silent wonder that's funny
all right let's let me let me check it
out
sorry about that yeah we're good we got
it
hello welcome back it's good to be back
what i was saying but you couldn't hear
me because i'm stupid
um it's been a while we've had like what
than a half month and a half since our
last wonder that's funny since our last
watch party so okay here we go i got my
my chat up here now i can see kind of
looking at the camera so i don't have to
look to the side i don't want to charge
i just got done playing a hockey game
like 30 minutes ago
i have sound now
that was chris
yeah it's been a long time since the
watch party it's been it's been uh
look he muted me of course he did the
god of mischief is up to no good
guys loki is like
i know i've said this like each time
like
i know each time i have
said like the new disney plush show is
like
the best disney plush show but
i genuinely believe it look he muted me
the god of mischief i play it yeah so i
played an adult league in hockey i
played a low level
uh professional league
when i was younger
when i was in my 20s
and um
it's been 10 years since i played and
this was my third game back
and uh i'm just out of breath the entire
time but tonight's game was at 10 45
and i'm like oh dang i have to go live
at 12 30 my time
so i like rushed back here i just jumped
in the shower i don't have hot water
because i forgot to turn that on uh
in my new house i've lived here for like
four days now
you guys can see the new setup here
into a tizzy david henry bennett thank
you for that super chat i don't know if
that's a like a good thing like tizzy or
uh
or a bad thing
but thank you for the super chat um i'm
very excited i'm very excited because
loki's always been
just such a good
character and he's deserved hit like the
spotlight he's deserved spotlight you
know um
and he's finally getting that and and
the way that this show is
you know set up for a second season
and
it's just it's an extremely important
show for a character that i really
really love right because he's like bad
he's like good and you know and now we
get him new it's a whole new story arc
it's you know it's not the excuse me
it's not the loki that we saw
die i mean do i have to say spoilers for
infinity war i feel like we've we've all
like seen it right
uh mr anderson in the chat
thank you so much great guy my moderator
does an insanely good job
he deserves to be praised thank you for
being here again i know we talk but
um
guys in the first episode i see mephisto
in the first episode
you are going to say mephisto but the
director came out and said um you know
it's not mephisto
and um
you know you know before sorry before
she came out
and said that i was i was already back
on it i was already prepared i was
already prepared for the mephisto
theories like
um and you'll see you'll see like and i
think it's in with like the first five
minutes maybe not first five minutes
first ten minutes for sure
i'm like oh great mephisto theaters are
back
and a part of me is like well
like maybe she just said that to like
get people off of it you know i i have
no idea um but you're gonna see
and even though the director came out
and said
it's not mephisto i still people are
still gonna say it
i'm only partially convinced it's not as
well you know because if it is you're
not gonna ruin that and come out and say
it uh noah ag official
uh thank you for the super chat first
and foremost i really appreciate that
that do you think i will really like the
show i'm really excited i i think so um
i personally love it
uh it is my favorite so far
because
and this is you know i don't mean this
in any insult any other character but uh
i have more invested interest in loki
than i do the other characters actually
wanda i had a pretty good invested
interest in um
i think if it would be like the disney
plus shows i would be like loki wanda
sam
bucky
that would be my list so far as like
story what i wanted to see because i i
really want to see want to become
scarlet witch i wanted to see
the falcon become the new captain
america but loki is the god of mischief
he's
awesome
uh so i do think you're gonna like this
it's really it's it's really really well
done
and owen wilson and tom hiddleston kill
it they kill it like it's so good
uh max conrad thank you so much for that
super chat it has been a very long time
but i appreciate you always showing up
in the chat i appreciate everybody
always showing up in the chat
and also in my videos you all are
awesome
uh
aloha from hawaii hello
uh a perez voyages daniel parkin anyone
know run time yeah it's 51 minutes
that's at least what the screener was
for me
um
is cleo thomas in loki
uh not that i've seen so far
actually i need to
pull
it up
disney plus
and just like always i'm gonna i'm gonna
kind of like show you guys you know a
little bit i obviously can't show all of
it because that's illegal
i don't see it popped up yet
let's uh let me get you on the stream
hey sean haynes
i think that's how you say that sean
haynes thank you so much for that super
chat and thank you for that compliment
um
so i haven't released my interview with
the writer yet but one question i asked
him was
you know because the writer wrote
multiverse of madness as well which you
know you might know that because of your
comment um so the writer for loki also
wrote multiverse of madness
and i asked him in the uh in our
interview i said you know did you
intentionally
do things in loki that would affect
multiverse of madness
and he kind of like stepped around the
question he he he generally answered he
was just like oh look he always causes
chaos and i was just kind of like
if it was no you would have said no but
you didn't say no
uh so yeah
t nasty nelson
uh
is there a way to contact me about
theories um you can dm me on instagram i
get a ton of dms
um and i do always try to go through
them
it just takes me um
some time to go through them but uh my
personal instagram
uh how do i i can't i'm not signed into
the chat how is that even possible my
personal instagram is cosmic warren
so just instead of wonder it's warren my
name uh find me on there follow me um
and dm me
uh comment on like my recent videos
saying that you dm'd me that's always
the best way to get in touch with me by
the way my personal instagram
um
and to comment in on a post of my
personal instagram saying that you dm me
that's usually the best way to do about
it
um voice is low low audio i
i'm listening on my phone here
and it's pretty loud uh
a lot of people saying audio is okay
so uh
yeah maybe try turning it up maybe it's
a setting something like that um
i don't yeah i miss a super chat i don't
want to miss a super chat sa sarfarez
khan hey that's a little dancing guy i
like that thank you so much for that
super chat uh
agrian garuji i'm so sorry if i did not
pronounce that right but thank you for
that super chat um
uh oh two super chats thank you agrian
and they don't say anything those super
chats
same with star pharah so if they did say
something i'm not seeing it i apologize
um
but regardless i appreciate it i
appreciate everybody being here in the
chat right now
i i love these watch parties they're so
much fun uh even though they're so late
at night
i just played a hockey game and i just
took a
really quick shower to
like right before that's why i was a few
minutes late i apologize for that i'm
still
here on oh sorry i was gonna pull up
disney plus for you guys
let's do this put this in front of me
and we're gonna
sorry baby yoda we're gonna cover you
we can put it here i guess let's put it
right here
there we go
let's see
switch computers here let's see
that's me
uh
yeah there we go
not here yet
i think before it was there you just
couldn't see any
you couldn't you couldn't see any
episodes but usually i think it's out
i guess not
um
and also for the people asking if i've
seen it yes i have i've seen the first
two episodes i don't think they're
releasing two episodes tonight um
because for one division
they screened
we got to see three episodes before
and only two came out the first night so
i think this is like in falcon the
winter soldier we only got to see one
before
and only one came out
so i think
um
i think
we're only getting one tonight uh see
you super chat matthew king thanks for
the super chat do i think the spider-man
trailer drops tomorrow uh
is today the ninth now yeah it's the
nights now uh so do i think it drops the
10th
i'm i'm hesitant to say this but it kind
of feels like it's going to doesn't it
i uh i don't want to give people's hopes
up um
because i don't you know i don't want to
people to be let down uh and that's why
i tried i've tried to limit my
i've tried to limit my spider-man like
trailer update videos i don't want to do
too many
um
i know people love them it's crazy how
many views they get um
and that's why i keep doing them because
i know people like them but i i don't
want to spit information that i don't
think is going to be you know pretty
credible but i think everything that
we've heard so far about the 10th date
uh seemingly adds up that doesn't mean
it's going to happen but
it does feel like it right
it feels like it
minecraft is updated
uh it's confirmed it's coming out i mean
maybe i hope
i hope
i really do
um and i hope
uh audio scenes oh it's out it's out all
right it's out
let's go let's not crash i don't have it
yet
i don't see it
let's type it in
loki collection how about just loki
okay
all right here's episode one i obviously
can't show the full screen you know the
whole entire whole entire time
uh
but yeah here we go
[Music]
so the first part is just kind of a
recap of new york as you can see here
and they're taking them away
so that's all we're seeing
i can't show too much because it'll get
copyrighted
i'm gonna open this
hulk is going down
here let me uh
full screen it here
alright we are 40 seconds into it for
those of you who are watching as well
ant-man
and this is just going to show loki
escaping
and there it is
2012 avengers
and goodbye loki
and here we go
just doing the marvel intro right now
did i
okay cool
for those of you talking about k-pop yes
i do i love k-pop it's like what i
listen to more than anything and i
actually speak a little korean
but we are talking about loki right now
and marvel studios just turned green
and we are beginning
uh for those of you who don't have it up
on disney
plus uh search the title loki i it
didn't pop up on mine until i searched
it
so mongolia desert is where they're at
right now it just told us that and loki
just flies out of the sky
and hits the ground
uh
hahaha
i am loki
of asgard
who are you they don't speak english
bruh
and here's the tva popping up
and we've seen this scene i put it in my
video today
i beg your pardon
i hereby arrest you for crimes against
the sacred timeline
and they do explain that
if they don't mind
this is your last chance you guys this
part's so funny
get out of my way
[Laughter]
sorry oh
that's so funny and
moving at 1 16 speed but feeling pain in
real time
and now he is theirs look at that he is
theirs now
reset the timeline that's like it's so
important and she has the tesseract
and then they reset the timeline using
these devices and that's it's
that's such an important thing moving
forward just in the mcu i'm not talking
about anything i've seen so far it's
just an important thing moving forward
in the mcu and they have loki and he has
no idea what's going on and now he's in
the tv
what is this place
he tries to run
nope reverse in time
he doesn't get it
this guy's funny
can you tell me what it is
it's a tesseract be very careful for
it you cross me deadly consequences
we'll see
hahaha
this is fine asgardian leather
and
it's gone and shirtless tom hiddleston
well i guess everything less tom
hiddleston
get the cat
and we've all seen this part please
verify this is everything you've ever
said
this is upset
this is absurd
um
i forgot to do something
to my knowledge
do a lot of people not know if they're
robots that's so funny
i need to turn this on there we go
look he's worried about if he's a robot
because he said some people don't know
they're a robot
not a robot so i should be fine
is he a robot
please take take a tab
take a tap take a ticket
and the other guy does not take a ticket
take a ticket
so tom or tom loki takes the ticket the
other guy doesn't take a ticket
shouldn't be here
so this this is an incredibly important
part
all right so here's where they explain
the whole timeline
a vast
multiversal war insanely important
and everything almost got destroyed
the time keepers
sacred timeline
uh for people talking about spoilers
yes um we talk about spoilers it's a
watch party
so
variants different variants of different
characters
whatever it was
created a nexus event
could branch off into madness endanger
multiverse multiverse of madness
the tva has stepped in to fix your
mistake and set time back on its
predetermined path
and now you must stand trial for your
offensive
and that is where loki is now
for all time always
look you don't like loki doesn't believe
any of it so this part is crazy
this guy doesn't have a ticket and
you don't yell the tva because boom you
forget obliterated
excuse me
loki desperately searches for his ticket
and
loki
alright
all right
hey fireflame thanks so much for that
super chat oh okay guys guys guys this
is the mephisto part yeah look he's
great fire flame 62 thank you for that
the painting of the
stained glass in the background i mean
excuse me
reset charge is gone
i freaking love owen wilson's character
stand down
for those who looking for it on disney
plus search it type type in the name
loki that's how it pops up
all right so check this out guys
that's joan of arc in the background
look
look at the
glory of the devil slash mephisto
this is insanely important spoilers
coming up right here do you know who did
this
points to the devil
don't worry that devil is afraid of us
we're going to take care of it i mean
i'm glad the director came out and said
it's not mephisto because
that is all i'm thinking about right now
i mean the director said it wasn't fisto
for those for those asking
uh
but to me hope it sure does look like it
right i mean
so
hmm
i mean how i mean
sir
there's something you want to see
yeah i can't show the whole thing guys
it's illegal
so loki's on trial right now though
how do you plead
a god doesn't plead
are you guilty or not guilty guilty of
being the god mischief yes
absolutely not you have the wrong person
now who should we have the avengers
owen wilson comes in
she just said what the avengers did was
supposed to happen you escaping was not
because the timekeeper said so
we should speak gods to gods
how do you plead
guilty of this
nope
[Laughter]
hold on everyone
he's trying to use his powers
magic powers no good in the tv mister
laughs and i love that
you're going to erase him
and here's our boy owen wilson mobius
thanks sriram appreciate that
sorry keep coughing guys
so the comic she's actually kang's lover
and he is just
he's gotta pop up
this is so cool i love this
i've kind of burnt the space place to
the ground
and loki is all of a sudden realizing
what the tva actually is
excuse me
tell me this i'll show the screen in
just like a second
tell me this look like star wars
right
tell me that's not star wars
isn't it
it's like star wars all day and i love
it
look
i mean that's
that's so we got the time keepers
holding up that middle spot there i mean
but that that is freaking star wars
hey stampede gorilla thanks for that
super chat
oh i need to make
this place is nightmare there's another
department i'll help you burn that down
isn't that crazy
hey thanks again stamping grill
agent mobius
we've all seen this part i need to make
a note for a video
you love to talk
doki takitaki
time passes differently in the tva
the dynamic between these two is insane
hey show patel thank you
episodes 51 minutes long
and here we go
this feels like you're gonna kill me
kind of room
how have i never heard of you till now
because you've never needed to
and he's gonna try to do something nope
reset him
let's get into it
these two are just freaking
tom hiddleston owen wilson i mean how
freaking awesome are they
[Music]
you don't know anything about me
[Laughter]
he calls tom hiddleston sloki a pussycat
because there are dangerous more
dangerous variants than him out there i
love it
king of what
what do you want to be king of
midgar
earth
i love
loki
he's
he tells him he's a fan
dang y'all really making it hard for mr
anderson there huh can we stop spamming
please
big metaphor guy it makes you sound
super smart
i'm smart i know
they're they're guys
third chemistry is so good
and now we get to see
everything
that look he was doing in the past
a sample of your greatest hits these two
characters
i mean how cool
he's just watching the show
some soda
[Music]
it's so funny for someone born to rule
you sure do lose a lot
no
ah
[Music]
phil coulson
the adventures come together to
literally avenge him and defeat you
perfect
i know what i am
a liberator of eyeballs maybe
hmm
i want some soda more drinks jaundice
here
the db cooper
[Music]
look at this
yes mr cooper i love it
i have a bomb
[Laughter]
oh tom hiddleston
i love it
look at him i cannot love this guy
this is the best part
brother
heimdall
you better be ready
people question me whether he said that
in the trailer and he did he said
heimdall
of course this is in the past
and
by frost money flying everywhere
i can't believe you were db
he lost the bet to thor
that's
so funny
loki's going to get up and i was going
to put him down
standing up to make a point
i am reading the comments yes
welcome first time to the stream
for those asking to show loki i can't
show the audio i can show you some
footage every now and then because it's
illegal for me to show you the whole
thing
but i'll talk about what's happening
loki just doesn't believe the tva is
powerful
and yes guys spoilers
this one
so loki basically is struggling with the
fact that
the tva is saying that fate exists and
he's saying no i make my own destiny
hello allegion
you're pathetic
you're gonna start taking things
seriously
now's where it gets intense
so they're showing him what would have
happened if he didn't take the tesseract
so he's never seen this before right
it's a different loki so he sees his
mother
please don't make this hard
what's up the mandalorian
john thank you iron man chair
where am i pointing
we don't know we don't just know your
past the tva knows your whole life how
it's supposed to be
and now it gets intense for loki
so he's the future that he would have
lived
i'm doing good caleb how are you
but instead you send them to kill your
mother
and then loki
loves his mother
dang
you lead them right to her
it happens again and again and again
because it's supposed to because it has
to
uh guys i'm not deleting the comments my
moderator is and he's leading comments
that are spams or inappropriate comments
so don't spam and don't say
inappropriate things
and you're good it'll be good
metallorene that's funny
you were born to cause pain
and suffering and death that's how it is
that's how it was that's how it always
will be
and you're supposed to help others
achieve their best versions of
themselves that's hard for loki to to
hear
loki i love how he struggles
tom hiddleston did such a good job look
at him he just struggles
he can't accept this
what are you doing
my job
we have a situation
uh guys people talk about spoilers we
show spoilers i show a little bit of the
screen
you can come back after the episode's
done
for uh the discussion about it
because a lot of people can't see this
so that's why i show it
and is loki gone
oh if you guys are crying now wait till
you wait till you see what happens
hey what's up loki welcome back
uh jay fergie wait till you see what's
coming up man
yeah i've seen the first two episodes
the mandalorian
uh how far are we into it ray g let's
take a look-see here 34 minutes 20
seconds
and loki has escaped and they're trying
to get him
don't so she's saying that she's gonna
reset him
which means kill him
and uh he says no
don't do it because he can he can help
us
excuse me
give me the tesseract or i'll cut you
like a fish
first episode 51 minutes
excuse me i'm sorry
this part's pretty intense
so spoilers coming he opens up the
drawer
check this out
and look what's there
just a whole bunch of infinity stones
and loki how do you have these
we get a lot of them
some of the guys use them as
paperweights
and he's just baffled that those are
infinity stones just sitting there
that they've collected
and he's starting to realize
he realizes loki has just no power
yeah they're real infinity stones that
people have collected
through variants coming you know the tva
taking the variance and now loki's
starting to realize like holy crap the
tva is
he's about to say it right here
is this the greatest power in the
universe
the tva is the real deal and he's about
to get erased
nope but he's fast
isn't that cool yeah caleb right i mean
it's like
i
loki realizes like
now he has to take the tv seriously
because
he just realizes like
this this tva is actually the real deal
he's literally
powerless right now
uh we're at about 36 minutes and the run
time for the show is
this episode is 51 minutes so now i i
love this so now loki's gonna just sit
there
and he's gonna go through his future
because remember he's never seen it he's
never seen
dark world ragnarok anything
and look i freaking love this he gets so
emotional
he gets so emotional and it's so great
looking at his dead mother
like anybody would
and then
watching his father go
dang
i'm just going to soak this part in guys
because it's so it's so good
watching his family go away
looking at thor
seeing him actually fight by a thor
as a good guy
i'm here
but then
what does he see here
and then all of a sudden it gets real
what's up malek how's it going man
and then
loki's about to uh
watch himself die right here
you
will never be
a god
dude
tom hiddleston what an actor
and then watching
that watching himself
die his brother by his side
how freaking epic it that whole thing
and then the tape runs out
because he died that's
his future
man
isn't this amazing i love this show
and he just laughs
and here's mobius
oh no it's not movies this part's good
get him away
nope nerd
but look he's got tricks he always has
tricks
throws it on her
and guess what boom
definitely glorious loki definitely
glorious
look at him
huh
just freaking messing with her right now
[Laughter]
oh man
[Laughter]
and then he realizes
he's in the tva and they are
powerful
was that my evil warren left was it
nowhere left to run
and he realizes i can't go back
can't go back to his timeline
i don't enjoy hurting people
he's a child that's funny i'm mobius
malik
uh ibrahim daruni i think i said that
right
uh yes the episode is out
bide you
you do know yourself that's so good
he said i'm a villain and mobius says
that's not how i see it i love this show
i gotta put it smaller i'm gonna get
copyrighted
you tried to use it yep
doesn't work
even an infinity stone is useless here
the tva is formidable that's hilarious
oh
pr pr anderson
a variance been killing my minutemen
and you need the god of mischief why
because the variant we're hunting is
you
oklahoma
1858
freaking minutemen going at it
trying to find this loki variant
yeah i i personally think it's the best
mcu so far
it's so good
early third millennial
nope no magic or anything works in the
tva uh
oh
remember when we thought this was doctor
doom
yeah y'all went in for a nice little
treat
there boom
boom
[Music]
yeah
nope
and now
she killed all of them
this loki variant is the real deal
boom and that's it
man
written by michael waldron i interviewed
him yesterday
he had some great things to say can't
wait to post my interview
all right let me stop this oh man
guys
how incredible right i mean
i mean how incredible
how incredible oof
it's insane
uh for those of you saying i said cheat
there's there's so many different
variations that that you see
um they are searching for someone
specific which i won't say but they're
they're uh there's a lot there's so much
cool stuff coming uh
it's really cool it's really cool it's
it's uh it goes in a way
um
that you kind of expect but don't expect
um
i'm not gonna spoil it
um
yeah
uh how did i get to where i am now like
press conference and stuff well
that's a good question because i can
answer that now because um
a lot of people ask me that i am going
to get chris in here so we can start
our
discussion
uh one second
let's pull up chris's youtube channel
and we'll get him in the discord
it was good where am i at where's chris
at
cosmic culture
cosmic it's so hot in my freaking room
it's insane i need to turn the fan on
but it's going to be so
all right we're going to do that now
let's uh
how do i do this i think i do it like
this
maybe not man i don't do it like this i
don't remember how i did it guys it's
been too long since we've
done a live stream i don't
remember
uh you know what i i
um
i don't i heard them say they confirmed
the second season
but then i looked for it and i'm like uh
i don't know i don't uh
i i don't i couldn't find any like
confirmation about it all right
chris just said call me in discord all
right we have to do that a different way
then here we go
call calling chris and discord
hello chris and discord
oh i don't think chris can you hear me
i can hear you
yeah so
for those asking about mephisto if the
if the director didn't come out and say
that
um it wasn't then we would all be going
crazy right now i was going crazy the
first time i saw it and i was fully
prepared for the mephisto theories
and then she came out and said that it
wasn't him and i was like ah bollocks
lame
ding ding ding
so what does everybody think
i'm like
yeah this is the first time i like
re-watched it i only saw it you know we
only watched it the first time
and
oh hold on they can't hear you
um
talk
hello i am chris they can hear you
now
thank you
so
the character development that they did
in 20 minutes oh my gosh i know it is
insane it's so insane that's okay that
was like my one of my favorite loki
moments
oh it was incredible it's one of the
best character developments ever oh yeah
he watches his future
and
just
first of all tom hiddleston's acting
whole it's incredible it's incredible
incredible the man is
a crazy talent a god
a god you know somebody you know when he
when he and by the way everyone those
spoilers in this chat if you're just
joining yes there are spoilers
man yeah just uh it's insane isn't it i
mean and this is an appreciation that i
suppose you and i have going through it
for a second third-ish time kind of
watching this now yeah
but as i'm sitting there watching the
part where he gets in the office with
mobius to the end
just everything they did to loki
that he had to go through the
realization of everything and him
realizing that and it's cool because his
big quote is
i'm burdened with glorious purpose yeah
yeah and he learns that he isn't no
you're not you're not burdened with
glorious purpose you're actually
murdered with zero purpose well his
purpose actually as mobius said was to
make other people
better and then they show the avengers
so he gets teleported to the gobi desert
then to the tva goes through all of this
stuff has his whole life hashed out in
front of him sees that he killed his mom
all of that stuff and on top of it finds
out that the purpose that he thought he
had
is irrelevant and that there is a fate
and then when he sees the infinity
stones and all this it comes and it
clicks and the acting of tom hiddleston
in that moment when he sees the infinity
stones his face yeah
the appreciation that he isn't in charge
and his glorious purpose isn't what he
wants it's incredible it's incredible
i'm buzzing loki right
loki's he says it i was meant to rule
you wouldn't understand i meant to rule
and then all of it like seeing the
infinity stones and going is this the
greatest power in the universe because
they don't work right he tries to use
tesseract doesn't work and then it's
like
he just realizes like i'm in trouble
like this is so much greater than me and
i'm a god right i'm supposed to be a god
and i am powerless is it the greatest
power in the universe yeah hold on real
fast uh channel the great thanks for
that super chat can i explain why they
made it an exception for the avengers
time travel not loki
do you think there'll be ramifications
for the avengers later um
no i don't and the reason is is because
one of the big parts
for loki's character development excuse
me
in the show
is he does not accept
what we call destiny fate
he says i if i do something and i ruled
it's because i made that choice right i
did it not because some god yeah not
because there's a tva monitoring blah
blah blah
so essentially it was the avengers
destiny
to go back in time it was thanos was
supposed to happen the snap was supposed
to happen the avengers were supposed to
go back in time but it was kind of
supposed to be seamless for them right
so hulk wasn't supposed to smash iron
man excuse me and loki wasn't supposed
to get the tesseract escape so that was
and loki even says it sometimes he's
like oh so that's not a big deal like oh
so this isn't a big deal blah blah blah
blah so fate's a big part of this um
uh
to katsu hoshi
thank you for that super chat and i hope
i pronounced that right um if i didn't i
apologize i have to really use the
bathroom guys so i'm gonna step out for
like 30 seconds chris is gonna entertain
people that's me i'm chris i will
entertain you
we had a busy day
um
but guys for me the thing to take away
from this episode is those two things
we've talked a lot about loki's
character development
but
the beginning the trailer that you see
from the little time keeper the little
weird one division-esque thing where
they talk about the multiverse and how
it could be created and nexus events and
all of this it's explained to us in this
crazy way
that
you know you have to understand
it's just nuts
these are the biggest multiverse
explanations we're going to get and that
we have gotten and you guys should be
really really excited that jackson
slater thank you yes it is chris mr
anderson how are you doing today man
um let's see what's going on benjamin
says i love how mobius and loki
connected so the characters yeah tom
hiddleston and
and owen wilson as well as mobius and
loki obviously their
flow is insane on the show the episode
has aired already andre and we have
finished it and honestly i think loki's
my favorite show so far it's incredible
yeah definitely re-watching the episode
um i got a spider-man chair
hello welcome back i've returned also
for those people staring at my chair the
giveaway that i'm releasing i think
probably this weekend because i'm in
collaboration with the chair company
will be this weekend
you can come see the spider one man
spider-man one on my channel
yeah let's uh
i got you pulled up on mine
yeah i'm gonna have to it just sucks
that it's delayed no worries don't worry
about it yeah you're delayed on that too
um what am i doing here we go okay oh
man that episode got me so pumped
it's a great episode
this series is gonna be so good
so i have i have come up with my idea
okay of uh
what i think
my my my prediction of how loki ends
okay we have a prediction here on how it
ends yes here also hold on did i miss
any super chats while i was going
because i apologize if i do
doesn't look um i don't believe you did
i was checking cool beans cool beans
good beans
all right
theory on how loki ends
from
cmr
that's me zamar so
i'm gonna say
your your camera is like super out of
focus yeah i already focused i'm like 40
seconds behind so i'll focus in a second
for you so you're gonna put um you're
gonna say
so loki's goal
loki is loki loki is loki that is a
factual statement he's not gonna stop
being
loki he's gonna continue
trying to figure out how to get out of
this he's discovered there are fates
he's going to want to beat the fates
right we can all agree on that
i think he does
i don't know that i can say it it agrees
that he's going to survive past it but i
think he's going to destroy the tva or
cause a nexus level event that tva can
no longer control
right yeah
it's going to go beyond their ability to
control it yeah
and that is going to lead us to the
multiverse of madness because that's how
things fall out of whack is when the tva
loses control right
and i don't know if it ends with loki
coming out alive somehow escaping or if
he ends up losing his way in that
but when that happens
we're going to get the whole multiverse
crazy and that might be how we get into
no way home right the multiverse is just
in ruins the tva has no control
and now all these multiverses are
crossing it's causing all these problems
and that leads to no way home which
eventually leads to the multiverse of
madness and doctor strange has to fix
everything because the tva is in ruins i
think for sure that's how it is real
quick uh
to
host hoshi thanks for that another super
chat i think for sure so
uh something i'll say that i uh i said
earlier but i'm i realize that probably
a lot of people are uh are here
um
that weren't here before so i
interviewed the writer
michael waldron and he wrote obviously
loki but he wrote doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness as well and so i
asked him literally my question was and
i'm gonna post this uh probably not
tomorrow but probably the next day i
asked him i said hey you wrote both
these shows
and one is literally called the
multiverse of madness and the other one
is literally dealing with like time
travel and alternate timelines and all
this stuff so i was literally like
were you careful
with loki
to not create things that affected
doctor strange or was that inevitable
did you intentionally write some things
that that affected
dr strange the multiverse madness and he
he he did what he had to do he stepped
around my question
right he because he's not going to come
out and say oh yeah loki's going to do
this in episode 4 and then doctor
strange is going to have to fix it up
instead what he told me
was
loki's always causing chaos right
because my question i said something
like you know is the chaos loki causing
something doctor strange is gonna have
to fix
and he basically was like well look he's
always causing chaos you know and i
think it always affects the mcu and i
was i didn't say this obviously because
i'm trying to be respectful of the fact
that he can't tell me spoilers
um
i was like okay and i left it alone but
in my mind i'm like
yes
i plead the fifth
like to me
to me that's that's it uh
yeah the the dance around answers
are real
dance around the real answers so well
yes mr anderson and you've been doing a
fantastic job tonight moderating
uh do i think thor will show up
no i think we'll see him like we've seen
him
yeah
i don't think we'll see thor either i've
been asked that a ton that's like the
number one question actually guys will
we see thor in this or loki and thor i
don't think either of those are gonna
happen no um for those talking about
spoilers uh this is a discussion about
the episode we are talking about the
episode um i can appreciate the fact
that you don't want spoilers so i
suggest and i don't really say this you
you you leave
you say that humbly because we want to
hear
but yeah oh okay so
uh but we're talking about spoilers so
you know i want you here but i don't
want to spoil it for you so sorry caleb
clifton asked me this earlier and i
started to uh answer this uh people want
to know how i got to how i am or where i
am today to be able to interview um
you know some of the cast and go to the
press conferences and chris now is on
the press conference list i did it
because he's been doing a good job over
his channel um
so basically you know i've been doing
youtube for
three years over three years now
and it started as fun
and it's still so much fun right but now
it's my business um this is how i make a
living now i'm so grateful for that i'm
so grateful for all of you
and eventually got to the point to where
i thought wow i could do this um
i
i could actually maybe
be legitimate in the eyes of marvel and
then hopefully later on warner brothers
which i'm working on right now
um and it's going well can't say much
but um and then you know other other
things um
other things so i basically started
reaching out to people and you know at
first it was a lot of
we're sorry no
a lot of no emails back a lot of new
calls back
a lot of kind of just a dead end
until eventually someone from disney
actually reached out to me
and they said that
a lot of people have emailed them about
me
and
i was brought on board
they said i'm going to add you the
specific person that i won't mention
by name
said i'm going to put you on the press
list and i'm going to work with you and
he stated you know you're not going to
get actor interviews you know right off
the get because you have to prove
yourself but you know he said uh i like
your youtube channel i think it's really
good um they did ask me if
like anything came out that like really
really really really really wasn't
supposed to come out to not post it so
like when the
uh one division
there was like a scene of one division
where you know like quicksilver was
dressed up in the halloween costume all
that that light leaked and everyone's
like do the video on it i'm like i can't
so stuff like that um
so yeah
so that's basically what happened is you
know i think at first when i reached out
i didn't have the credentials which
would you know be the following that i
have now um and they looked at
everything they looked at like social
media blah blah blah blah um
instagram twitter and all that stuff uh
you know people would tell me no
um
and i think just because i didn't have
those credentials when i first started
reaching out to people
i think i had like
like 250 000 subscribers which to me i
was like dang that's a lot right but uh
people don't take youtuber seriously
because it's new media is what it's
called right they they want the outlets
like deadline and variety which i
totally get
but uh someone at disney
um who i i actually we i texted him
yesterday after the press conference and
he texted me back and
took a chance and um
i'm so grateful for it i'm so grateful
for all of you supporting me and now
chris because that's
all we can do
or we wouldn't be here without you guys
so thank you so that's that's how
the credentials are following and good
content
i mean that's really what it is right if
you're disney and you trust somebody to
interview somebody right you have to be
professional right um you have to have a
good work track record you have to have
a good following and and you know they
basically have to know that one you're
gonna spread the word about the show
and two you're not gonna be an idiot so
hey to get you hoshi again thank you so
much
oh thank you tim wonder i appreciate
that let's turn chris down a little bit
i remember that happened last time
thank you for that i apologize to
everybody else
so so yeah anyways
hey thanks patch p uh i just you know
just want to bring you guys good content
i do my best to update you on everything
that's going on uh just because i like
just so everybody knows like just
because i you know i have contacts and
stuff like now it doesn't mean they're
sitting there telling me when stuff is
gonna happen that is that is not what
happening i am uh
you know it's i don't know when the
spider-man no way home chill is going to
come out that's also sony anyway so my
disney contact marvel conte probably
want to know that
uh
so what
so i got a cool super chat from jake
asking
essentially does doctor strange know
that the tv exists obviously we don't
know this but what do you think
no i i don't
i don't either i don't think so because
i think it's the same as the avengers i
think whatever
he is doing is supposed to happen
exactly right i don't think he knows
they exist i think when all comes
falling apart he's gonna become aware of
something
like i said my big theory was doctor
strange could be the only one that can
put the multiverse back into
you know the sacred timeline if that's
even possible we might actually not get
an mcu with a sacred timeline moving
forward after doctor strange that's what
i think is gonna happen i think
obviously leading the secret wars
obviously i think the beginning where
they showed all the different timelines
at war with each other blah blah blah
that was secret wars
i'm not saying it's i'm not saying it
already happened we're never going to
see it right but that was like that
essentially was secret wars we're going
to get that
in
the future somehow right i don't know if
it's ten years from now five years from
now it's not five years from now we have
enough time
for uh since endgame has not passed yet
um
but i mean
it's secret wars right different
timelines
fusing into one it's like essentially
what they did so here's what i think is
gonna happen
and i just think it it makes sense based
off of what we know already
multiverse of madness
there's going to be multiple
timelines the sacred timeline is not
going to be just the main
one anymore loki will create a nexus
event which the tva can't undo right
that's going to be the problem and from
there other it's just going to branch
out like they show in the beginning it's
just going to branch out and branch out
and branch out and just
and yeah
so i agree with that that's exactly
where i think my headset after watching
this and and understanding the direction
we're going just based off of the title
of doctor strange in the multiple
differences right and which is the which
is the best kept secret marvel has ever
had we've gotten absolutely nothing
about that it's so funny right how we've
gotten nothing about that but you know
what's funny is they literally kind of
said multiverse of madness they said
everything would get thrown into madness
and then they said danger multiverse and
i'm like right
literally
madness like is that not like the
biggest clue in the history of marvel
like this is heading into this direction
oh 100 multiverse was thrown into
madness now now now also something else
something else kevin feige in an
interview wasn't variety
empire
don't quote me on this but
kevin feige said in an interview
i'm gonna say was empire magazine
that
loki is the most important
show so far and will
it is tremendously important that's
literally what he said it is
tremendously important it's gonna blow
phase four out of the water this uh
it's so
there's no way it's just the sacred
timeline at the end of at the end after
the loki there's no way
no and i i definitely not by the end of
the loki and i'm gonna even go ahead and
say probably not by the end of the
multiverse commandments
wait what
the sacred timeline isn't going to exist
after i don't think it comes back
i don't think so i don't think maybe
there'll be some
order maybe doctor strange will be able
to get some order in the in the madness
so i don't think that we're going to be
back to the to where we were so that's
the way that marvel goes bigger than
infinity war yeah i think so uh dominic
gonzalez i agree with you so for
starters i think all three of the time
keepers are king
definitely the middle one because he
kind of looks like jonathan majors i've
seen fan art of jonathan majors as king
and he looks like that middle one
granted it was animated but i
think
all of the timekeepers are actually king
because kang has like thousands of
different versions of versions of him
because he is the master of time travel
and who
who's in charge of the tva who's in
charge of time the master of time travel
do you know what i mean like because
remember there's different versions of
king some are good most of them are bad
so we can see a good king and we can see
a bad king and that
will be cool because he'll have to fight
himself
he'll have to go against himself and i
think that would be really good uh kane
conquerer is depending on which story
you go by because the comics
changed it
is a descendant of reed richards
or
a descendant of doctor doom
depending on which story i i like to
read richard's one because his name is
nathaniel richards
and basically he
he lived in the future
where time travel was illegal but he got
his hands on an old time travel device
and he restored it and he went back in
time and he ran into the fantastic four
and they kind of thwarted his plans
because he was like ruling in egypt and
from there on out he like devoted his
life to defeat the fantastic four and
the avengers
uh real quick nick cc thanks for that
super chat
do you think the multiver with the
multiverse going into collapse we'll
find a way to make all the netflix
marvel shows make sense aka daredevil
uh i don't know if
they'll find a way to make them make
sense but i do think that that
definitely opens up the possibility
for those characters to come in
in some way shape or form i um
i think it would be a missed opportunity
if they didn't um
uh isaiah richardson jr i don't remember
where i saw it
but in an interview someone said kang
will not appear in loki before quan
dominion thanks for the super chat yeah
the only thing is if he was going to
appear they wouldn't say he would right
right um just like jennifer miscellany
saying yeah that's a rumor i'm not she
hulk and then a month later kevin feige
comes out in the disney investor meeting
saying and then here's she-hulk with
jennifer and selena right it's like they
they literally can't so you have to keep
in mind
so
you have to keep in mind that they sign
nda non-disclosures agreement and
basically if they break those they get
sued
and fired
and
you know it's just it's bad so it's like
a legal thing they literally can't spoil
things um
and i
it's funny when i talked to the writer
of loki i asked him a question
and then i was like you know to the best
that you actually can't talk about and
he said yeah not without getting killed
so that that's kind of gives you an
insight on how strict it is over there
you know uh
no it's um
the whole setup is insane it's reason to
be excited for marvel fans who are
following closely if you're not
following close you'll probably be
confused yeah i love that did owen
wilson say wow yet i know right it has
to be in there at least at some point he
will one more time it has to be in there
one time he has to say wow he he has to
say wow
what's your chair
somebody said nice chair i said so much
so guys i have the iron man chair
how do i move i have the iron man chair
and chris has the spider-man one and
we're doing a giveaway and uh well
actually antecede's doing the giveaway
with me um
coming out this weekend i believe and uh
winner gets to choose a chair of their
choice i also have an ant-man one
but i don't know captain america and a
captain america one they're all just
super cool you'll see them pretty soon
he better say wow i mean
please
please please say well it'd be such a
missed opportunity i actually love the i
love the
loki was in such like awe in the
beginning of
like what's
happening
and the guy is like
to the best of your knowledge are you a
robot and he's like to the best of my
knowledge do some people not know
they're a robot and then he stops
and he hesitates to go into the machine
because he didn't know he was a frost
giant at first he spent the first
thousands of years of his life not
knowing he was a frost giant right
because he asked what happens if i
wasn't like oh you'll just get melted
from the inside out and you like
hesitate yeah right like uh
right but that's like
that's so clever
that's just good
writing
yeah yeah so barton
agnes sorry if i didn't pronounce that
right um
you're right about that whole there's
that nightmare uh scene where he's like
oh that's another department yeah you
can burn that i'll help you burn that
place down that point nightmare in
charge of it right
right
the nightmare dimension or or does that
get escaped when the multiverse flies
into is that something else the tva is
in charge of containing
like there's so much possible like once
the multiverse breaks anything's
possible
everything is possible fox characters
netflix characters deadpool
you know deadpool fighting sonic they
could literally do whatever they want
sonic yeah
once the multiverse breaks the
introduction of anybody it all makes
sense it all be clean it's a really cool
direction you know huge clap on
on marvel kevin feige all of them for
this this awesome orchestration and it
was interesting
because in the conference we were in
yesterday was it two days ago now
when they asked kevin feige was this
always the plan for loki when you killed
him he said he didn't know no yeah he
didn't know even even when he took the
tesseract in avengers end game and
disappeared they didn't know what the
plan was for him
right just an awesome orchestration a
really cool way to
to put everything together
and i'm super excited to see where it
leads this there's no way this doesn't
connect to spider-man
and dr strange it's 100 percent
connections are strange i don't know
about spider-man because you have to
keep in mind that
sony is part of that but then again they
have to abide kind of by their rules
yeah uh real quick
versus sonic dawn of disney yeah right
uh real quick kmk thanks for super chat
love the episode i did too uh curious
why the tva plucked loki when they could
have just raced him when they erased the
whole timeline was it due to mobius yes
so
yes it was due to mobius they have to
stand trial
right so they grabbed him right after he
committed the crime
put him in all the clothes tripped him
away of as fine as guardian leather as
we saw
and then he stood trial and they said
are you guilty and so they said yes you
are guilty and they were going to erase
or reset him which is a you know erase
them they're going to kill him but then
owen wilson stepped in and said
uh no i think i have a purpose for him
and spoil alert coming up right here
one two three four five six minute nine
ten all right that's enough um you know
at the end owen wilson said the variant
we're hunting is you
and he actually said in like the middle
of it that he specializes in dangerous
variants and he called loki a pussycat
so we know that the loki variant that
he's chasing down is a lot
more powerful more powerful more evil
right we'll see when we run into him
i know this isn't why we're here but
i've been asked so many times and i'm
going to ask you because if anybody
knows or has a thought on it it's you
are you talking to me obviously you've
heard the rumors about the spider-man
trailer dropping tomorrow one through
ten
do you think it's coming out uh six
okay wow six sixty percent okay
just because somebody asked there's a
lot i've been at the back several times
today yeah i've addressed what you
thought
we're gonna be half asleep
mr anderson ninja turtles vs power
rangers mcu yes
um
delay official do you guys think loki
could find himself in mephisto's realm
the dark dimension in his travels
between realities thanks thank you for
that super chat yeah i think so i think
anything's really possible here um
and you know even though the director
came out and said it's not mephisto
maybe it is
what is she gonna say yeah it's mephisto
she can't
right uh and i'm not gonna you know
start the whole mephisto is here
again because
no i'm i'm going on record and saying no
no what did eric vos say kang gang
that's where i'm at right now i'm on the
king game i'm off the methister train
i'm on the kane game yeah i'm with uh
i'm with eric voss on that one i'm on
the gang that guy's
that guy knows what he's talking about
he's the
best so
[Music]
oh crap so we learned something at the
end or i guess throughout the episode so
we know it's the loki variant that
they're hunting right
we know he's scarier than the current
loki variant that mobius was talking to
our loki we'll call it our loki our loki
the one we know and love
we also can depict based off of what
we've seen in this first episode
that this loki is aware of the tva
because he's encountered fought with
them and stole equipment from them four
different times right yeah i think i
think at the end it was
that last one at the end was the fourth
time i believe right so so definitely
aware of who the tva are are destroying
the minutemen which is what they call
the soldiers collecting
and collecting their equipment the
devices they called it yeah they're
reset charges charges there you go
yeah so
the plan what is this loki variant
trying to accomplish
is it tva related is it something else
related so that's the direction that's
the big cliffhanger we were left with
and i think if we put those pieces
together we can kind of get an idea for
the big idea future of this specific
variant so here's what i think is the
variance goal because you have to keep
in mind
that the variant is still loki right
however different he may be because in
that little animated thing they showed
us like flashes of like you know what
was really big one was small almost fat
blah blah blah uh
so he could be anything but
he's still loki
right
loki
wants to take out the tva loki wants to
make
his own destiny
not
you know given to this whole
you say i'm this person and that's who
i'm supposed to be
no
excuse me that's that's not who he is he
is going to
and i'm talking about the other variant
that they're chasing now he's going to
do everything he can he can to
burn down the tva like arlo he said i'm
going to burn this place to the ground
that's the goal
right and that's why owen wilson
mobius wants this loki to get inside of
the mind of loki to help right because
they need to get inside of the president
right right right so
you know
i'm guessing at some point in time
there's going to be a really big attack
on the tva that's
for sure that's right
maybe drop so what so the tva exists
outside of time what happens if you take
a timeline eraser thing resetter and and
and it blows up in the tva what happens
then
right the multiverse of madness happens
i guess right right so is that the end
right i mean is that the end um well
what the big question for me is what
happens so these variants can obviously
exist outside of the tva as this second
loki has
wait so that means there is hope for our
loki
to write his own face right i thought
about that too yeah so since this loki
varian is going off and jumping
seemingly jumping through different
timelines and stuff like that
and the tva can't and the tv can't catch
him
then it's it's definitely possible our
loki has
well first of all look i don't think
it's like there's i don't think there's
a way that this ends with him dying or
anything like that right i hope not it'd
be i don't think he's got to fit into
the future so right right maybe he ends
up bleeding the tv and becoming the god
he wanted to maybe right maybe lobby is
king
well moebi that could be crazy mobius
drops the
god of the universe i believe it is
right god of space loki king of space
maybe that's how that ends it does like
that and the tva might be in absolute
crumbles and he's not the king of much
but he ends up being in charge of the
tva true
um
but i'm also going to be really ticked
off if owen wilson's character mobius
goes away but uh cam k i mean how does
he fit into the future i know right
another super chat thank you so much
why wouldn't others from that timeline
stand trial though for example the guard
that wasn't watching loki as he grabbed
the tesseract or cap fighting sacred cap
so
pretty much anything the avengers did uh
and this is what i talked about in one
of my videos
like they explain everything and
some people aren't gonna like it because
it's almost like an easy way out right
oh like we're not trying the avengers
because that was supposed to happen but
fate is a big part of what is happening
here that's a big part of what loki
struggles with is fate and this series
is kind of him overcoming his fate and
saying i make my own fate
so
the guard that let loki
go or whatever keep in mind the tva
doesn't exist in any timeline they're
outside of it right they're just outside
of it right they're outside of the
secret timeline so there's no
consequence of that directly to the
timeline it could be if he got away and
like went to a different timeline um
so that's why that person wasn't put on
trial uh because they exist outside of
the timeline hold on well they perceive
blue out of the water one of my big
theories that i've been talking about on
my channel over here
about captain america having to have
dealt with the tva for what he did
because that was one of my big thoughts
was well captain america can't be gone
there has to be a detail somewhere where
he gets in trouble with the tva for what
he did
but you know he's like you want the
avengers it was them and it's like they
did what they were supposed to do they
completely puts that hole together yeah
the theories about that are done now and
remember it's over and it was supposed
to happen the fate right it's about
destiny and fate um keegan low don't
forget according to rumors the turtles
are robots i don't know about that
but maybe
do some people not know their robots
who knows right are we robots
i i've blood before so i'm gonna say you
know unless it's oil
i don't know i am so excited for the
rest of the season
uh i i
this show i think is going to
this already my favorite disney plush
show by the way oh for sure and this
episode gets a 10 out of 10 from me i i
think it was a flawless episode and you
know um
they said that they
after each episode they made they went
holy crap that was the best episode
well here we go let's let's ride
i personally really really enjoyed
episode two
um
i enjo i think you might have said you
liked episode one more
i preferred episode one yes i liked
episode two
i really did no don't get me wrong
episode two was was great
there are so many aspects to episode one
that are just so incredible
it was hard for me to get over there
there's a lot and it's a setup so it's
really cool because
yeah there's different aspects to it you
know there's a lot of different aspects
to it but
jake hedge says i just want to thank you
and warren for having this show and
allowing the theories to bounce around
it really helps me with my research and
you guys are awesome thumbs up thumbs up
thank you so much jake yes thank you
thank you thank you for hanging out with
us yeah thank you to everybody who's
hanging out with us because all of you
guys make it fun across the board
uh jackson think about super chat since
the tva keeps the secret timeline intact
are they then hypothetically aware of
the other hero universes remy fox
universe etc
that is a great
question
because in the beginning of this episode
we
were told
that the the other universes are
combined into one
so again that kind of leads me to
believe that by the end of loki we're
going to have multiple different
timelines and i think that's where the
remy versus the fox universe all those
are gonna gonna come in or come
back
if they were one of the timelines fused
before maybe
maybe
the sacred timeline just gets undone and
all the universes that were are now
back that's a possibility maybe and it
goes straight back into the war that
they were talking about
picks up
yeah and that could be like imagine you
like take a rope
it has different threads in it you wind
it together
it's tied nicely it's one rope and yeah
and tie that rope again and the strands
go right back where they were that would
be
a cool theory and some are fragile right
because
from what we've heard about leaks and
stuff like
some uh alternate realities can be
falling apart
and and inside that thread already
exists god emperor doom i'm scared
yeah
that would be freaking i cannot wait
till dr doom freaking comes in
uh i i'm dying waiting for doctor doom
almost more than even deadpool but
deadpool's definitely number one camp k
again
super chat i appreciate it avengers from
the branch timeline all got erased
without seeing a trial i'm just trying
to figure out why loki got a trial
and they all didn't well he's the one
who messed it up right
um because
the the ones from that branch timeline
stay in their main timeline right it's
only loki
that personally himself creates a
different timeline as weird as that
sounds but basically
those other avengers they're not really
affected
they're still part of the main timeline
right um and they will eventually go on
to fight thanos and then they'll go back
in time
and they'll see what happened and it's
basically just you know an endless cycle
right um
but it's all part of the main sacred
timeline time travel is so tricky
to write because there's so many
different excellent job yeah i think
they're doing a good job there's so many
different aspects to time trouble
mm-hmm which makes sense right so a lot
of people view time as linear
um
but that's not the only form of time
travel right that's not the only way to
look at time parallel there's a lot of
different things so
essentially what
it's hard to explain but essentially
it's just a loop right so the avengers
interfere with 2012 events but it's
supposed to happen so the avengers from
2012 go on to be the avengers that
interf fear in the 2012 like it's like
an endless cycle right um just on and on
and on so loki when loki took the
tesseract he himself got off so there's
like the two timelines right
or there's the sacred timeline and when
loki himself took the tesseract he and
himself only created this new timeline
so he got taken out and that timeline
that he
created got erased not the main timeline
not the main avengers but the one the
different one
they did get erased
and that's why he stood trial because he
created a new timeline yeah and that's
all stuff as you guys go back and watch
it and you look at these little charts
that they have that show the sacred
timeline you'll see
these branches leading off of it that
they're trying to return to the main
timeline and that's what they mean by
reset like they wouldn't delete loki
from history they would delete what
they're calling this variant of loki and
reset it back to before everything went
off yeah uh so here's a good question
right here uh if lucky created his own
timeline how did the avengers carry on
uh
to be the same avengers without having
the tesseract because in that sacred
timeline that didn't happen
it all doesn't matter the bran shot was
only created because loki took
the tesseract so in the main timeline
he didn't take it
and that's the whole idea of the tva is
to protect these variants from branching
off and causing ripple effects right by
resetting them i feel like we could
really
dissect i feel like there's always going
to be holes with time travel this is
basically how i feel well quite frankly
i don't think there are a whole lot here
i understand like they do a really good
job explaining it
like it's confusing and it's hard to
wrap your head around but i don't think
there are a lot of platforms no and i
think it works very well it does and i
think that's a
well one
setting up the multiverse of madness but
two
i think that's one of the reasons having
one single sacred timeline is smart
because it makes it easy
and it makes that's what they're
protecting right so basically it's uh
it's what they explained in avengers
indie game they're kind of going up the
same thing if you go back in time
and
kill hitler then you're not going to
stop
world war ii from happening in the
future you are going to create a
different timeline
so the future that you're in the present
that you're in that's always it
right so essentially you can't change
that
so
the sacred timeline that's always going
to be the sacred timeline
and um
mobius said
every single time
you die right every single time you lead
the dark elves to kill your mom every
single time your dad dies you do this
every single time
and you've always done it and that's how
it has to be
right right that's how it is that's how
it will be
alexa hey
i believe you're in my other if in i
believe it's the same spelling believe
you're in my other watch parties as well
thanks for being here why i'm glad to be
here even though it's 4 30. i feel you
it's 2 30 here uh just read they made
loki gender fluid i don't even know why
this is important to the story but i
wonder what are your thoughts um i i
can't give you them because i've seen
the second episode and you'll understand
in the second episode
just keep so just keep in mind there
we're we're doing a loki
and we're doing a show about loki
that has a bunch of different variations
of him
there there's gonna be and they've all
been rendered in the comics
right so in the comics you have
lady loki kid loki
frog loki i don't know if there's a frog
look there's a frog thor um
you know there's so many different
variations and they kind of like
explained that in the beginning
i'm so i'm so sorry
um
there's just so many different
variations and i think we're going to
see a lot of different variations of
loki in the upcoming episodes um
not
any
in
the next episode
but
i mean some actors and actresses are
confirmed and stuff like that um
that's all i'll say
and
they've already set it up to be you know
different variations and you know he's a
variant and they're searching for
another variant of loki um
i wouldn't be surprised if we actually
saw a different variation of thor at
some point in time or a different
variation of
something else a stranger some puppy
loki hopefully hopefully we get puppy
okay but i i think i think
you know that's another fun thing that
marvel could do with it right like
any variation of loki that you could
possibly think of they could do
right
so
i don't know
uh i think there's so much we could be
here all night talking about what we
just saw in this episode and then you
know the next episode
as we already know has even more and
then more and more and more and to
you're at the top
at the top next level and the next level
and the next level
and then at the top and then you're at
the top um
but absolutely incredible a ton of
reason to be excited for marvel tonight
of reason i'll be excited um
is the best yeah i'm gonna ask people to
stop uh super chatting now because we're
about to end this and i don't want to
miss any but i appreciate all the super
chats tonight i appreciate all the
comments tonight i appreciate everybody
who's just came by to stop and watch and
i just got a super chat um
josiah heath thanks for the super chat
do you think at the end
excuse me loki will turn into a kid
and that will be kid loki for young
avengers
joshua uh
i think there could be a variation of
that right um
but maybe maybe the tv is like hey let's
reset
you and you'll be a kid and maybe you
can have a different
destiny
uh
you know than otherwise uh hold on to my
muzzle
andrew
oh say goodbye to chris everybody
i'm leaving go subscribe to cosmic
culture if you haven't yet
yeah subscribe to me
christopher i try really hard it does
try really hard
put a lot of trying into it all right
guys uh have a good night i'll see you
next week bye chris
he's actually in the room next week
he'll probably walk in here after oh
goodbye bye guys
uh andreas thanks for super chat the tva
has the ability to reset timeline so any
fractures the avengers caused an in-game
would have been manually fixed
by them very clever right yeah it really
is and thanks for the super chat it
it really is i think they did it in a
way that makes sense
and
i think that's hard to do with time
travel um
i really do austin rolls relays rolls
here's my theory i truly believe that
loki being the variant they're hunting
is a misdirect and that he is being
framed by kang in order to get what kang
may need or want that's a great theory i
really like that and thanks for super
chat i think kang
even though they've said is not going to
be in the loki series i
i think we've already seen kang um
those animated time keepers in the
beginning i think the middle one if not
all of them was kang uh i really do i
really think that middle one looks like
jonathan majors who is going to be
playing kane so i think you're i think
you're you're sp i don't know about the
misdirect because i don't
we don't really know who's the main
villain right and it could be kang and
that could be awesome
uh monster
js2608
so thanks for super chat so what do you
think about kang as one of the time
keepers also was mephisto reference as
well i'm not sure he just caught what i
said about king
i think he is one if not all of the time
timekeepers different variation of him
right different variant of him
um because they're you know in the
comics there's like thousands of
different versions of king
was mephisto referenced
let's just say no um
the director came out and said it's not
mephisto yeah she could be lying because
you're never gonna say yes it is
mephisto
um i'm thinking maybe a variant loki
could be like a devilish kind of person
he can't shapeshift you know so uh
because that little kid did say you know
the devil did this uh maybe that variant
of loki is the devil i'm not sure i
haven't seen that far into it and
uh
i wouldn't be surprised if it was though
so
i'm going to say no to mephisto
but i do think mephisto's coming
whether in the loki series and
multiverse of madness when they visit
you know the hell realm or something
like that i
i for sure thanks coming and maybe it
isn't looking
but before the director came out and
said that
my mephisto theories were primed
and ready to go like i was ready to go
back with this two theories um that it
is what it is all right guys it's 2 30.
i have to do a video
tomorrow today
today i guess um i'm going to be doing
an indian explained which is going to
have some important topics in it and
then the next day i will do my full
20 minute 30 minute ever long breakdown
uh you know trying to go over every
single thing i could possibly find in it
is what i'm going to be doing so
uh
i believe eric boss got the second
episode i can't imagine he did it um
i i couldn't imagine he didn't everybody
i that i i know like real rejects they
got
the first two as well so
uh multiverse is definitely real um
elia elia
i love you too thank you um you guys are
all awesome you make
this so much fun
so much fun um and like you know like i
said i had a hockey game tonight i'd
been up all day um got to do some work
after this but i i i wanted to
do these still because i love them
they're awesome and they're awesome
because of you guys so thank you all
everybody uh i just want to make sure i
don't miss anything uh thank you to mr
anderson big shout out to mr anderson he
is the best monitor uh moderator uh he's
really awesome uh do i talk to eric uh
i have before and i've been on uh new
rockstars before
as a guest which was really really cool
that was a really cool time for me
eric's uh awesome guy from want to know
about him um there's chris in the
background hi chris
bye bye chris
um
i have only good things to say about
eric voss he's
i thought best of what he does new
rockstars is awesome and all the guys
there seem to be really cool everyone
i've talked to there seems to be really
cool but no we don't chat like on a
day-to-day basis or anything like that
um he likes my tweets when i tweet about
them
so um hey
thanks so much everybody for stopping by
today um i know it's really late for
some people i know it's
early for some people it could be in the
middle of day for some people no matter
what time it is no matter where you are
in the world thank you so much i love
you all uh look out for the vids coming
tomorrow
woof